[Applaudissements]
je vous demande d'accueillir isabelle
comme il se doit
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que vous en pensez la
fouille mais les plus vrais que nature
patson véhicule que vous n'auriez pas vu
des rappeuses comme ça olala ça c'est la
cerise sur le gâteau mais moi je trouve
que ça vous va pas malade kim chue de
rire c'est ça montre suisse et le
drapeau suisse
vous pourriez faire un petit rap pour
voir comment est ce que vous rappeler
comment ma forme je sais pas les
ouvrages et pas ramener les carottes et
le rap au septième art est une amie mais
lorsque je trouve que ça vous va sucre
je vous assure
franchement ça ne va pas super bien
aller avec la fouine a laissé un petit
duo tous les débats ressemblent à des
danseuses sur mes clips et ouais non
mais francky il a tout à fait un petit
rap tous les toutous la mer mais si tu
veux me cacher je ne réponds pas
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait les faire
chanter
vous pourrez chanter tout qu'est ce que
tu pourrais me battre c'est quoi comme
on reçoit marc lavoine j'aimerais que tu
me rappelles a les yeux revolver aura
pas mal pas mal
bonne idée ça me met toutes les
intonations l allègement çi prévoit le
piment à la une fois que j'écris ce
revolver voulait pas voulu venir à côté
de moi tous les 2% ce matin
oh mais attendez vous pensez caméra est
bien beau mais c'est la première fois de
ma vie que je vois une jeune la bonne
vaste zone
[Applaudissements]
pas tous mais
batîment au nom et ouais c'est le
maillot de nicolas tôt bon alors les
yeux revolver
elle est naturelle à la faute et c'est
foutu
j'appelle les gars
isabelle pouvait savoir je vous aime
d'un amour infini
vous êtes extraordinaire et je crois
qu'elle est prête pour les anges de la
télé réalité